welcome to this video here stuff
eighty-five ninety one probably at son
norway ok so a king's indian i get let's
play the other buck and play that for a
while not a bad line ok ok i have to
prepare a F 494 ok i could have played
93 maybe that splits probably the
theoretical recommendation there but
let's play it aggressively whoa really i
have time for that luxury luxurious
moves you five night h5m okay let's try
that okay so night h4 is a possibility
night she's free then
or just Bishop d3 then let's go Bishop
d3 I played that a bit too quickly
should have considered it a little bit
more if it's really that great and while
black setup is very likely not not very
good probably my try and refutation is
also not very good or at least it could
have been considered more careful in
itself okay let's do this check what the
crazy position hmm oh okay if you moves
that night Queen h5 isn't that strong
don't tell me that this isn't dangerous
for black
what is your big big point now
so before i'm playing again such a quick
move here at queen h5 ready looks like
the way to go so I can check him first I
wonder if that is a good idea I think it
should be a good idea or not may I think
can't be a good idea so take it check
Wow
just need to check on the F failure as
simple as that to hear Wow for the
position don't give me that crap what
what I work who who's got that idea that
sets that's just amazing trapping my
queen air I have to go queen age four
and then he takes my bishop what's this
did sets that's nightmarish check
unbelievable I've believable stuff
check
it's still interesting not the king what
the game check so how to do that now
maybe it better said something better
than just capturing I don't know let's
chance take first ask questions later
when German has charmed and farm Bishop
g8 that that's just amazing that move
okay so check isn't that somewhat strong
the discovery the discovered check oops
come on check give me that look check so
black resigns good heavens so I gotta
win and out of that water wacky game I
help help help and I'd f3 is bad i am
but ok i was a bit too aggressively
minded yeah a six looks very relaxed
about things she can take that time but
probably five is some yeah not so well
child no it's not really great now
bishop is six given as good and black by
the engine this is amazingly enough
supposed to be about equal check but
here i don't get to believe that one so
what is the comp giving night age 5 and
this this chain night f4 yeah this is
the i didn't edit absolutely not
consider bishop g8 as a possible we
should be forced given via the engine
with equal chances or bishop c2 with a
slight advantage
computer chess so I went here blundering
this move and now I'm not objectively
lost after that however it's not that
clear due to g6 of course yeah that was
also an idea Bishop f5 is however check
seems to be winning here remarkable yeah
okay I went here he went here check and
this is seems to be a draw with
challenges seven but this is losing
check check I could have played Knight
b6 there already that wins anyway I was
a very very messy and weird game okay
well thanks for watching